back in june 2020 the world saw gameplay
from death loot for the very first time
revealing its slick gun play cool as
hell aesthetic and an intriguing mystery
to unravel the video was met with
roaring excitement from me included
for fans the chance to delve into a new
world developed by arcane was exciting
internally however deathly wasn't quite
garnering the same enthusiasm with a lot
of play testers not even understanding
what the game was right until the last
minute we were still getting these
really tough reports telling us of just
baffling frustrating mystifying problems
that like we could not see coming what
kind of [ __ ] the world is
death loop is a game about trial and
error to comment problems over and over
again from different angles to shift
things around until it all makes sense
which isn't that far off from the game's
actual development this is the story of
the redesign let's say death
our story starts with dana nightingale
one of arcane leone's lead designers and
the campaign director for death loop the
simplest way to put it is i
have to take care of the game's critical
path
so i am responsible for the player's
main experience from the moment they
press start until the credits roll
you may not know her by name but if you
play an arcane game especially
dishonored 2 then you definitely know
her work you have heard a thing for the
iconic and mind-boggling clockwork
mansion mission who would build
something like this def loop is arcane's
most ambitious game to date it's a
culmination of all its design principles
with an intricately designed systematic
world special powers and an open-ended
approach to playstyles with one major
addition it's set in a time loop and for
the player breaking that time loop
involves a game-long puzzle to piece
together and solve you play as cult and
amnesic trapped in a day-long time loop
on a mysterious island called black reef
which is run by eight eccentric villains
known as visionaries cult is being
hunted and killed over and over again by
someone named juliana the objective of
the game kill all eight visionaries in a
single day to break the loop now that's
an extremely simplified explanation but
accompany that with a massive island to
explore puzzles and investigation
abilities loads of characters and
different times of day and he'd be a lot
to convey to a player but for dana
that was kind of the intention to just
drop the player into this world with
little guidance and just have him figure
it out
there's an edge piece we finally had the
moment where the full campaign had come
together and we're ready to say okay
players consultants user research
experts play the game from start to
finish and tell us what you think and it
was pretty dire
it was uh it was rough in august 2020
only a few months after the games
gameplay reveal arcane shipped off an
alpha build to its user research team
and feedback was
well far from good
no one understood it
like any of it they didn't understand
why giuliana was hunting them let alone
if she was a friend or foe they didn't
understand that killing the visionaries
broke the loop it was unclear how gear
worked and how to keep it between loops
and some players couldn't even decipher
they were in a loop at all one of the
core elements to dana's design was to
give the player freedom to figure
everything out themselves but the lack
of guidance was
leaving players lost we thought we were
going to be redesigning the beginning of
the game to teach the player how to play
the game and then after that had
actually achieved all of its goals it
still wasn't enough and we had to go in
and kind of restructure the whole shape
of the game after that to be something
that
was actually comprehensible here is a
high level look at how the game works
black reef is split into four major
areas in which the player can explore
four different times of day morning noon
afternoon and evening going from one of
the four major areas to another will
trigger the time of day to progress
meaning the player cannot visit multiple
areas within the same time of day in a
single loop the eight visionaries the
player has to kill are spread out
through the four areas at the four
different times of day so if the player
can only visit four areas in a single
loop but needs to kill all eight in a
single run that's where the game's
murder puzzle comes in the crux of the
entire thing through investigation the
player has to figure out alternate
methods to eliminate the visionaries in
a single loop the gold and loop as dana
refers to it the end game if that seems
like a lot to take in well
that was kind of the issue a huge amount
of information was just being tossed at
the players and none of it was sinking
in so for dana it was back to the
drawing board but the only solution
being something that
went against her own design principles a
guided tour a linear path in which the
player's hands were lightly held through
all of its moving parts and pieces i was
initially resistant to the idea of
making this change because i really
loved how non-linear the game was and i
didn't want to back i didn't want to
give an inch
on that thing where it's like okay we
introduce you to this world and we say
go go wherever you want do whatever you
want being lost and confused is fun
because of the like the serotonin hit of
getting the answer but the game we had
made was a game where the player had no
idea when that eureka moment was coming
at that point in the game the way we had
design it is the thing to do next is to
go out in the world with no idea what
you're gonna find and just
stumble upon something for some players
that's absolutely satisfying and for me
that's absolutely satisfying i've played
games that work that way and i've loved
them
but in in this case it wasn't quite
working so what better solution than
creating a literal document in the game
that explains the loop to the players
called the loop preservation protocol
this dock would explain everything and
in order to get the dock the player
would have to experience the loop and
all the mechanics with it a very
cleverly disguised tutorial area dana
put the dock in a safe that the player
must find the code for the player is
tasked with finding the safe in the
morning doing some investigation midday
retrieving the code in the afternoon and
returning to the safe in the evening
only to discover that the safe had been
broken into and that the important
document was stolen this means that the
player has no option but to experience
the loop all over again but this time
armed with the knowledge of the safe
code so they can just go there first
thing in the morning and open it
bam
can't get more clear than that totally
comprehensible so they stamped pre beta
on it and set it off for another round
of user research
[Music]
and the results weren't good first the
good news players now understood the
time loop and that all eight visionaries
needed to be killed in a single day to
break the loop perfect but the bad news
was that a lot of players weren't even
finishing the guided tour many of them
would just wander aimlessly unsure what
to do next and they still didn't
understand how to keep their gear so
it was back
to the drawing board
this time they were going to add exit
markers to signify the player when they
were done with their mission and to move
on next they were going to make
investigation priority over combat to
instill to the player that finding clues
and leads was the key to piecing
together the murder puzzle and thus
acting out the golden loop and lastly
they were going to make killing one of
the visionaries at the end of the loop
mandatory which would in turn explain
how to keep powers and gear between
loops stamp beta on it and ship it off
the good news is that players are
actually finishing and understanding the
guided tour
the bad news is that most players found
it too puzzly they didn't even
understand how to skip time and some
were just calling it straight up boring
and tedious while some other folk
strangely
just kept referring to it as a roguelike
this time dana was going to spell it out
literally they decided to put in ui
tutorials they filled the menu with
pop-ups explaining every part of it this
button passes time this button chooses
where to go this teaches you how to keep
your gear and so on and so on there was
no room for misinterpretation that was
it they solved it pack it
send it up
then the players reached quit right
until
the last minute we were still getting
these really tough reports telling us of
just baffling frustrating mystifying
problems that like we could not see
coming players understood the game and
all its inner workings but instead they
were now getting stuck on a difficulty
spike from a visionary fight so more
work had to be done however there was
another looming problem for dana by this
time the game had for dana and the
team's benefit been delayed later into
2021 but even still time was running out
the budget had hit its peak and crunch
was not an option with no more time left
for user research and only two weeks
left to submit the final build dana had
to get very
very clever so instead of redesigning it
all together she simply proposed a
rearrangement of things
something like a 150 things so she sat
down with the executive producer
and laid it all out there was like no
room for confusion no margin of error it
was like we're going to take this pick
up and we're going to move it to these
coordinates we're going to take this
line of text and move it from this
document to that document we're going to
take this piece of logic and instead of
it triggering this is going to trigger
that i didn't have anything like we're
going to redesign that nothing like that
it was the exact specific thing that we
were going to change
and it was global it was like i said it
was like 150 tasks overall dana had all
the pieces in front of her they just had
to be rearranged in a way that could
make the bigger picture easier to see
and much like the mystery of the game it
takes picking up pieces one at a time
and fitting them in with others until
you have the full scope of what's
happening
but it's like okay we're going to make
this quest line start here and that
affects these 18 other things and i had
like in detail list them all and it was
true like the list of tasks i wrote that
was it and it was done the time came to
submit the game for its street date when
there was no turning back whatever game
they shipped
that was it
there isn't going to be
a second chance no one is going to come
back with notes on this and say hey
here's how to improve it you've read so
many user research reports by now try to
think how they think and combine that
with your experience and instincts and
then filter that through what's possible
in two weeks and then just jump
ironically the process of redesigning
deathly was much like the puzzle players
and cult were facing in-game and the
final pieces only fell into place just
days before the game was officially
released
and when it was finally released well
in the beginning dana wanted to create
something that embraced her principles
of giving absolute freedom to the player
to reward them with their own sense of
discovery by giving them essentially
nothing in the end however she needed to
loosen her grip and strike a balance by
incorporating things like a guided tour
or ui tutorials and so on but even
despite the addition of those more
conventional tropes death loop managed
to retain a unique and unconventional
approach rarely seen in the aaa space so
yeah she may have added tutorials and
waypoints but our core principles
were unwavered you can play it safe and
still fail
wouldn't you rather feel spectacularly
doing something risky and dangerous and
crazy like given the option between
failing doing something safe and feeling
doing something dangerous i'll take the
other one because like failure isn't
inevitable but it comes like from things
totally out of your control it paid off
and not just in review scores but
for dana two
i am very proud of this game
might be the the game i'm the most proud
of that i've worked on
[Music]